We're crushing our videos
into bite size pieces
for your inspiration
and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is King of Random Rewind.
10. ACRYLIC FIRE PISTON
9. H20 FUEL
8. PAPER CLIP LOCK PICK
7. POKEBALL CANDLES
6. VACUUMED SLIME
5. GUMMY WARS
4. GLOWSTICK EXPERIMENT
3. LN2 VS DRY ICE
2. ELECTRIFIED PICKLE
1. APPLE HACKING
Hey guys, Grant here.
Hope you enjoyed
this compilation.
If you like to see
the full tutorials for these videos,
we got links down
in the description.
If you like to see
another compilation,
click the box up there,
and if you're not already subscribe,
go ahead and click the bomb,
we'll see you in the next video.
Talk to you then.